everybody had just completely discounted
thought it didn't matter and the robin
hood investors ah we don't care about
them
they're too young they have no money
well that's not how it is
i can't stand the arrogance of
sophisticated wall street investors what
a load of crap that is
those guys just got blown up
[Music]
okay going out for a cruise um great
time to talk about the economy
i'm on your bike why not but before i go
into the sunshine here in miami
i got to put on a little s listen it's
really important i use the am or tiege
hanley why
because it's spf 20 keeps the dome
from getting damaged you don't want to
damage the dome the dome of desire has
to stay in perfect shape
so a little am spf 20 that's what i'm
talking about
um very nice
then of course safety first got to put
on the helmet here
also i'm a fashionista so i want to look
good and then of course
need some shades because we're in miami
right
that's what i'm talking about
all right so uh you ready to cruise all
right we're gonna take a cruise here
let's go
[Music]
you think of you know your basic company
in america let's say 50
of its sales go through retail i'm
talking about consumer goods and
services
which is about 65 of the economy so
50 go through retailers like walmart
target bed bath and beyond that kind of
thing
and then you got about another 40 going
through amazon that's how big amazon's
becoming when you sell it through a
retailer
like walmart you make about 50 cents on
the dollar
you sell it through amazon you do a
little better you make about 60 cents on
the dollar
however you don't have the benefit of
getting the customer's name
that's the big thing about amazon and
then most companies have 10
from their own websites to consumers
okay you got that
now here's what happens retail shuts
down last march
the companies that made it all did one
thing very successfully
they basically went online they set up
their own website so they
standardized on shopify then they
standardized
on docusign then maybe for security they
standardized on crowdstrike
basically they were using technologies
like wix.com to enhance their
whole platform their video their product
support
pictures stories animation graphics all
that stuff
they were basically doing this because
they wanted to entice people to buy
direct from them and those companies
they went up in value like crazy even
the middle of a pandemic
look at what happened to a zoom stock or
shopify stock you get it
but they were empowering america to go
digital that's exactly what was
occurring
now think about it this way instead of
selling something through walmart or
target or bed bath and beyond where you
made 50 cents in the dollar you're now
shifting your sales
direct to consumer will you make a
hundred cents on the dollar
so people say to me why is the market
exploding why is it going up in value
well
the market sense is a new america a
digital 2.0 america
an america where it's very productive
and where a lot of products are being
sold direct to consumers at very high
gross margins
that is something brand new
really new and very interesting and so
it's not just small companies big
companies are doing the same thing
nike 50 of his sales direct consumer all
around the world this is a global
phenomenon that's occurring
it's amazing what's happening and as a
result
we've accelerated the digitization of
our economy
but while that was happening something
else was occurring that's incredibly
cool too
social media kept getting more and more
powerful
storytelling more and more powerful
animation graphics
video you name it became more and more
important to any company
who are trying to figure out how to tell
their story
something happened recently that really
shocked everybody you know
people keep talking about sophisticated
investors on wall street the little guy
doesn't know what's going on
not anymore here's what happened you
know
the crowd basically led by reddit
and wall street bets which everybody had
just completely discounted thought it
didn't matter and the robin hood
investors ah we don't care about them
they're too young they have no money
well that's not how it is
they ganged up and went after hedge
funds who had done big
short bets on companies like start
engine and amc
and american airlines and guess what
they became the new force
on wall street the little guy crushed
the hedge funds
it forced them to lose billions of
dollars on their balance sheets as they
were caught with their pants down
as all these tiny players are mashed
together like a flock of swallows
and became really powerful now who's the
sophisticated investor on wall street
it's the little guy and now if you're a
guy that's shorting stocks or a hedge
fund manager think you're so
sophisticated and using all the ai
technology and black boxes
and algorithms and all that crap if you
get targeted you get screwed
and that's what's happening the crowd
roams
at night looking for opportunities in
the markets and strikes in the morning
and you see it happen every day and it's
a new force that's not going away
it's power to the people baby and i love
it
i think it really democratizes the
market you know what i really really
like about it more than anything else
financial literacy it used to be and you
know we've got
100 million americans that do not have
anything put aside for their retirement
because they were never taught how to do
that in high school
and everybody's saying well you know we
teach them sex education geography math
reading yeah we do all that
but why don't we teach some financial
literacy well along comes robinhood
a platform where you can have 200 bucks
and invest it
and start to learn the ways of the
market and how to put money aside and
how to invest and how to buy a stock and
how to sell one
that's financial literacy and millions
and millions and millions
of people started opening those accounts
and wall street never cared about them
because they didn't want an account with
200 bucks in it they couldn't make any
money off you
they want a hundred thousand two hundred
thousand minimum well robin hood said
hey for everybody else
wear your platform and bingo it becomes
a massive force in the market
incredible also very good so in a matter
of just
36 months 16 million plus accounts with
power to change the market direction do
i love this stuff
oh yeah i totally love it i can't stand
the arrogance
of sophisticated wall street investors
what a load of crap that is
those guys just got blown up
by who 25 year olds how cool is that
you gotta just love that so what's
really going
on is the democratization of the entire
global stock market
you know and the way to really make this
fair for everybody big or small
is total transparency if you're short
the stock and maybe
make the rule five percent of the float
you gotta post it and then everybody
that's cruising around looking for you
is gonna find you
it'll make you think twice before doing
that good or bad
it's transparent that's what matters but
the power
of the little guy now has been proven
and the way you prove power on wall
street
is money when you force a firm to lose
billions of dollars
you've got power baby that's exactly
what you've got and that's exactly what
happened
millions of small guys ganged up on the
big guys
and wiped them out
i still get a kick out of it i think
it's just fantastic
this is really the power of social media
and why we should protect it
it just shows you it gives prior to
everybody it's democracy it's a voice
it's a chance to shine even if you're a
single candle that's what the whole deal
is about
and together it's a bright light that's
the whole that's the whole deal
right there let me give you some
investing tips i've learned over the
long period of time
it's very simple you know what happens
in the market when you get a crazy week
like last week
when the market goes up 10 down 10
percent
you never know when that's going to
happen so you have to stay invested all
the time because last year
during the crazy pandemic period the
majority of the returns came in just 19
days
you just didn't know which 19. so if
you're trying to time the market by
buying and selling in the ups and downs
it's really hard to make dough really
hard there's nothing wrong with day
trading that's fun
but you got to take a portion of your
profits and put them aside
and i was involved in an app called bean
stocks to help people do that
it's not day trading it's long-term
investing but listen you got to take a
little powder keep it dry you take 10 of
your profits every time you trade
stick it into beanstalks download it
check it out i tell all the day traders
you guys have power but you've got to
take care of yourself long term take 10
of your winnings park them aside for
yourself
let it grow in the market over the time
between now and 40 years from now when
you retire
they'll have over a million bucks if you
just park a hundred dollars a side each
week
most day traders can handle that if you
like that video
where did you see my next one don't
forget to click right over here and
subscribe